three of three today is another Bernie
question the question is hey David how
should Bernie be handling protesters who
interrupt his speeches so we actually
had a voicemail last week from a angry
Trumpets ed bernie is weak bernie is
beta because protesters get up on the
stage and they take over the microphone
and Bernie just stands there now there's
a practical question and then there's an
ideological question the practical
question is that it's lose-lose for
Bernie because if bernie is speaking and
protesters come onstage and commandeer
the microphone if bernie allows them to
speak oh wow bernie is so weak and beta
that he can't even control his own stage
if protesters come up and Bernie
physically blocks them from getting the
microphone or snatches the microphone
away particularly if it is you know the
topless female protesters that have
recently shown up at Bernie's events
then oh my goodness bernie is a
misogynistic he's physically taking the
microphone back from these protesters
and brittle Alera so either way he is
going to be criticized by somebody now
the reality is go and look at Bernie's
background right Bernie's background in
the 60s sort of hippie activist movement
it's all about interrupting speeches
which is a non-violent form of activism
so I would not be surprised if when
Bernie has this happen to him he sees it
nostalgic Lee in some sense and it's a
throwback to when he was involved in
protest movements in the 60s and 70s
that did exactly this type of stuff now
I also want to point out and this will
get us to the to what is coming when it
comes to Bernie's a security situation
there is a big difference between
someone wanting to speak and be heard
versus someone looking to harm Bernie
Sanders or harm another candidate and if
Bernie Sanders is the nominee there is
going to be no shortage of people who
want to harm Bernie Sanders the
anti-semitism will explode and it's
going to be a mess so the real answer is
if you want to prevent this stuff from
happening in the first place and never
even end up in the
of having to stand aside while people
commandeer the mic or having to snatch
the microphone back from someone the
answer is you put in place more security
and this is ultimately going to resolve
itself because the major candidates are
going to get Secret Service protection
very very soon whoever is the nominee
will of course get Secret Service
protection I have a friend of mine who
works for a federal agency who actually
is going to be pulled away to do
additional Secret Service stuff during
the campaign and it's starting pretty
soon under no circumstances would the
Secret Service let anyone interrupt or
get close to Bernie on stage we saw a
couple of incidents back when it was
candidate Trump remember in late 2015 or
I guess it was more more 2016 yeah 2016
not 2015 where people started to make an
attempt to get on the stage or whatever
Trump is immediately pulled away the
people are immediately tackled so the
ability for anyone to grab the mic at a
Bernie rally is very soon going to
completely evaporate because of the
Secret Service protection that will soon
be put in place let me know what you
think how should Bernie handle it should
he just prevent it altogether with a
stronger security presence let me know I
don't think this is the most important
thing I do not evaluate candidates on
the basis of how they react to people
jumping onto the stage trying to speak
that's just not how I pick who I'm going
to vote for but maybe you're in a
different camp make sure that you check
out today's bonus show producer Pat
common deep speaking of commandeering
producer Pat has commandeered the Friday
bonus show check it out by becoming a
member or a patron membership join
pakman.com patreon patreon.com slash
david pakman show we then have the South
Carolina primary over the weekend we
then have Super Tuesday next Tuesday
which we will be covering live so a big
upcoming ten days for the David Pakman
show for progressive media and for the
continuing process of selecting a
Democratic nominee for 2020 we'll see
you then